مع انه الذكاء الاصطناعي لا يزال رضيعا
الا ان صح التعبير طبعا الا انه بدا
بالفعل يثير الكثير من الجدل والمتاعب هذه
قصه غريبه احد مستخدمي تيك توك سال الذكاء
عما تسبب بوفاه الاميره ديانا وصديقها
عماد الفايد بحادث سياره في عام 1997 في
باريس جاءت الاجابه صاعقه بالفعل بدلا من
ان يشرح بكلمات تفيد عن تفاصيل الحادث رد
بتقديم ثلاثه صور واحده لشبيه ملك
بريطانيا تشارلز الثالث او ربما بابيه
الراحل الامير فيلب
والثانيه لامراه قد تكون الملك الراحله
اليزابيث الثانيه فيما الثالثه جاءت
لسياره محطمه اشاره الى التي كانت تقل
الاميره والفهيد
يعني وكانه الذكاء الاصطناعي الاصطناعي
بعطيهم اختيارات يعني
واذا ما عرفتوش السياره ما هو هذا الكل
بعرفه انه السياره
الصناعي مال علاقه لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات